[Applauso]
questo iter tante tonalità iritale e
oggi andremo a vedere persone che
tingono i capelli di colori un pazzo chi
fumerà accesi quindi dei cambi drastici
di cappelli
non vedo l'ora perché mi piace un sacco
sempre vedere valori sono sempre
bellissimi da vedere ma soprattutto di
questa persona coraggiosa che decidono
di pezzi di colore colore spara flashato
di box quando scrivete nei commenti
secondo voi che colore e ci sarebbe un
bene di capelli che colore sarebbe bene
a me e che colore starebbe bene a verità
e arrestati pronti prima di pop corn
mettetevi comodi e iniziamo subito io
abbia una trasformazione con capelli
verdi o dieci li aveva quasi sarà
problema sono le parti ci si metterà il
venderà oggi io come voti starebbe bene
l'accordo giusta per provare un po per
vedere come stanno quelli quella aperta
tipo biondissimi dagli bianchi settimane
stanno adesso vediamo sono ancora
bagnati quindi va benissimo il colore
sono ancora bagnati ma io mi farei penso
è proprio tutti posti l'evidenziatore ma
che ciò che aveva 8 luglio
è un bellissimo effetto una super
trasformazione questo è il risultato
sembra una persona incredibile come il
colore di capelli ti cambia quindi
potresti farlo questo potrebbe farlo
anita del fumo no penso che sia una
lampada ultravioletti a noi spiega
abbiamo acceso così i ragazzi e ragazze
cilea biondi è un bellissimo colore già
sta facendo tutti rosa sta dicendo che
non ha comprato abbastanza tinta toccato
sembravano non ha comprato abbastanza
tinta quindi ha fatto vedere come stava
meglio naturale senz'altro lino però il
colore così una carota
no no adesso si vede di più no lo vede
riassuntive insomma la linea tipo i
capelli multicolor affisse un po di
verde un po di rotta e sta mettendo un
po di rosso accesissimo quindi a me i
capelli rossi mi piacciono tantissimo se
vi sono proprio curiosa di vedere il
risultato qua che si sono super a cesi
che ti stanno sanguinando le mani non è
facile correre
titoli poi diventano ma che saranno bene
anche io chiamo anti ciao belli così un
po sulla fronte sulla guancia ce l'ha
anche sulla destra dopo un po vanno via
però figlio mi piace il risultato
beccato ne pensate questo mi sta facendo
villa belli questi sanno bene anche
facile perché c'è dei capelli abbastanza
chiari o il cambio sono chiari il colore
prende di più nei mei non si vedrebbe
niente dovrei prima decorrerà de
colorarli per far vedere il colore
questo mi sa di colore che non è facile
il lilla che si renda e non è facile
riaprendo i tre super complicato anche
lì la mid semplice ecco come colore
mediano i riflessi sono belli sembra un
biondo platino con qualche riflesso
viola mi piace un sacco superbelli a
questa cosa di prima visione
vorrei questo no sorta di arancione o
giallo giallo sabbia mostarda sguardo
non ho mai visto questo colore di
cappello però bellissimo e molto
particolare ci sono di tipo della
sfumature verdi motivo questa silea
bianchi e di più facile che prende il
colore è finita sì decisamente
ma che cos'è sta usando blu for whom the
mi sembra un blu complicato far legni su
ciò che ci sono piani questo è il primo
è questo il dono one che è ben fatto
molto bene quindi devi calcolare li
stanno facendo di odio oggi c'e volonta
facendo qua e là si già nati proprio
sono biondi si wow
state attenti è se vi fate la tinta in
casa state attenti che si possono
rovinare tantissimo de colorandoli ma è
arancione si aprì malia decolorato per
far prendere il colore e ora l'estate
intendo di arancio fluo
superfluo bellissimi ma lei stanno bene
almeno un paio di fare protesi bene o
ruota che bello
voglio vedere capelli rosa questa errata
un po scuro fucsia come fanno a
sporcarsi la maglietta infatti hanno
forse queste non sono quelle permanenti
sono quelli da provvisori tv ma non
penso perché con questi colori super
forti penso che siano permanenti paio di
lanci pensate
perché la vedevo come lo applicava con
la boccetta quindi intorno
no penso che sia già mischia tenta una
torre da me non so complicato però forlì
domani infatti super bravi a farli se vi
facesse sarebbe un disastro
l'area secondo poi corre il miglior
colore di capelli tra questi colori fazi
quale colore mi piace di più a me ts un
fatto il rosso super acceso e anche in
rosa mi casa ma pensavo di cs il
violetto anche di ora è bello un carcere
uno a pensavo venisse non può più scuri
dal latino e tyson però si è fatto che
non li ha fatti vedere ai 70 grigie in
mente bianco biondo platino che sto
quasi bianchi sta facendo blu che bello
risultato basano sul pube lido vedere
questi signori guarderò per due ore di
fila ea tech e colore psi pietro questi
colori pazzo allora mi piaceva quello
arancione arancione fluo e poi quello
viola lilla ha fatto metà blue meta
perde pazzo ma va detto che la
bellissima con il risultato che strano
questa è una tecnica infatti questo lo
sto facendo un parrucchiere immagino che
oggi spalmi sulle sfumature immagino
servano sì non lo so come si mischiano
questo pettine strano non vedo l'ora di
vedere il risultato si pensa per le
sfumature rosa in arancio risultato di
vederlo è la stessa persona mi sa di sì
perché ha messo un altro strato vede sta
nascendo arcobaleno multicolor
certo fa un po impressione rometti sopra
o c'è sopra rimane di due colori e sotto
altri due colori
anche perché è complicato perché come
fai a lavarli dove c'è una file riesce a
fare tutto da rifare prima uno poi
l'altro
non so se norma letto il vero non penso
che sia formalmente non lo so però
l'effetto è fighissimo per carnevale
un'ottima idea questa qua e manotti
perché toccare i capelli perché se
rischiare fatto anche chi fa linea tonno
rosso rosso che ben lo voglio vedere
questa trasformazione non fa che
vorrebbe ben presente che sembra sangue
questo rosso così è successo sotto sono
scuri e lì forse nessuno ha fatto
infatti visto proprio tutti rossi allora
non mi piace moltissimo il fatto che
solo sopra siano rossi perché sembra che
stia un po stanco i nando è uno spaccato
sporca però io me li genera bellissima
ancora vicolo passi fanno pratica
immagino con i manichini di chi no sì
diciamo battaglia sta colando di tempo
arancione giallo che lo faccia tutto
arcobaleno verte vescovi kappeler gomma
nera che è piegata
[Musica]
nelle alcun palermo perché per una
persona reale una sono state particolari
peraltro sono solo delle ciocche sono
tutti coloro bello l'effetto non facile
ma che figata
io non so non penso che mi starebbero
bene però da vedere sono bellissimi
quella come sfumato questo a tutti i
colori pastello da sopra celeste viola
rosso e giallo
questi finora sono i vincitori perché
era disfatto qui bocca che proprio oggi
però ho mio zio questo incredibile
secondo voi quali sono i più belli
finora dov'è questi intenti con i
capelli già narrata stavano davvero bene
con il blocco l'esame 9 che anche adesso
sa che sono altri stessi
che strano vari colori che stanno usando
comunque strano ma che abbiano
protettivo con i capelli a litio
mariasol slay term avuto parecchio anche
questi stencil è queste bombolette spray
seguite corriere
poi ci contesta loro 98 di basta quali
razzo vediamo come questa trasformazione
in quelli neri sta mettendo il lilla e
per lo sguardo interessante farlo così a
strati perché si coprono meglio i
capelli mi sarà però mai nessuno perché
di leal sono decolorati prima sopra te
quindi sta facendo nero e rosso o forse
un viola viola scooter scuro viola scuro
è rosso è felicissima farmi fare tutto
trasformazione adesso le specie quando
già sembrano già visti uguali bello sarà
un mezzo diavolo rosso sono sfumati
impegni massaggio la tinta sembra che
abbiamo usato è una crema la bellissima
e darlo antrace l'altro a quello cattivo
da fatto al contrario mi sale di perché
ha girato i capelli come avranno fatto
così probabilmente con le bombolette
non lo so ma è incredibile oddio tinto
solo alcune parti quindi sono rimasti
tipo dei tre punti
ok
questa è la trasformazione più pazza che
abbiamo visto finora si guarda o devi
avere un tarlo il coraggio per forzare
questo sarà un gandola questa come fanno
nel pavimento che le racconta che bello
voglio vederli ancora rosa quindi non so
se farà delle sfumature forse delle
sfumature con il cross a rosa biondo si
sta mettendo il colore più forte davanti
forza sembrano già bellissimi pauroso
battello che bello e troppo bene questo
colore si sta ben visibile a me ne
farebbero malissimo così chiari perchè
questo nome nicolò rischio auguri spesso
i capelli più corto è più facile che
mantengano dic le immagini voilà sembra
un effetto 3d
vediamo un po la trasformazione a prima
vista e colorando immagino si soffra che
sono scuri e nel colore esattamente poi
nero o blu blu scuro facendo due colori
blue me sembra di vedere che tutta la
zona d'azione per un altro
questo tema anche rosa o i viola non
credo sia il più eletto
vediamo vediamo io o fucsia che belli
belli
ecco un altro arcobaleno mio alter
copertina quello di prima sostenendo
rifatto sì cioè mi sta venendo voglia di
farmi capelli di un colore fans
arcobaleno berti operativo
[Musica]
wow troppo bella sfumatura dalle davvero
no mi sta testando senza fare sì che
quel migliaio
diamo sta ragazza sembra che abbia i
capelli non tinti quindi come vorrei
misurare come di fare secondo te penso
che adesso li state colorate si sono
lunghi grosso o rossa facciona swan e le
classi so forse anche bello sopra degli
affarucci di poi al tifoso che sembrano
dei fiori o forse proprio l'effetto dato
dal colore che hanno fatto qualche forma
insieme tipo decorare con il prodotto al
colore con le varie sfumature sempre al
tridimensionale
[Musica]
forse c'è stata con i balli oppure se un
po d'italia sembra proprio 3d una come
visto un taglio è un colore del genere
voi avevate mai visto questi tagli su
per pazzi questa biondissima questo
prenderà tanto il colore al quale in
verde giallo era un altro rende ma non
pensavo che questi video sarebbero stati
cosi belli e divertenti da un utente le
faccio lo faccio marrone grigio e verde
ritornano che belle e idem rota viola
celeste poi fanno ciocca per ciocca di
quanto tempo ci vorrà fare belli così
tra mezza giornata da un giorno intero
un giorno intero probabilmente no
bellissimo brano sfumati bellissimo
somigliano a quelli che abbiamo visto
prima se bellissimi che si casta un
altro di quell effetto dell'aumento
dell'iva si sta formando nessuno ha un
colore da una parte rainbow lo stesso e
dall'altra sono scuri forse solo per far
vedere il colore ok treno tutti i tagli
i colori passano più colori che ciò gli
è piaciuto tantissimo vedere questi
colori pazzi bellissimi lasciate il
match se volete che ne guardiamo altri
assieme il più bello è stato quello
rainbow con i boccoli secondo me anche
secondo me quelli quelli rainbow in
generale erano più belli non l'ultimo
forse
non proprio l'ultimo ma il secondo che
abbiamo visto era perfetto per lei che
se volete vedere un altro video del
genere per lasciato scelta instant nei
commenti del colore che mi è piaciuto di
più oppure del colore che secondo voi
sarebbe meglio anno e ora vi lasciamo
qua 4 caselline su cui cliccare
provvedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quello che preferite tempo reale i
piani ciao